estamos en la tarea de verificar algunas
relaciones matemáticas con integrales
definidas de combinaciones de funciones
trigonométricas para que sea directo al
poder hallar los coeficientes de la
serie de furia verdad y en realidad ya
hemos iniciado el trayecto ya hemos
visto que por ejemplo la integral de 0 a
2 pi del seno de mt dt esto es igual a 0
y lo mismo para el coseno la integral de
0 a 2 pi del coseno de mt dt es igual a
0 para cualquier m entero que sea no
nulo es decir que no sea 0 verdad pero
de hecho voy a generalizar lo en
realidad este primer resultado es válido
para cualquier m entero aún pudiendo ser
0 verdad también podría ser cero ya que
seno de cero es cero y la integral de
cero pues es cero verdad ahora bien este
resultado de aquí abajo sí es cierto que
es para cualquier m cualquier valor m
entero que sea
verdad no nulo porque en este caso si m
vale 0 tendríamos coseno de 0 que es 1 y
estaríamos integrando uno desde cero a
dos y eso sería dos pi y eso por
supuesto no es cero verdad entonces ahí
lo tenemos vamos ahora a generar más
bases para poder trabajar con las series
de furia y ahora vamos a tratar de
calcular la integral de cero a dos pi de
un producto de xenón con coseno verdad
vamos a poner el seno de me porte por el
coseno de n por t de t y yo afirmo que
esto vale cero para cualesquiera dos
enteros y me llene verdad entonces para
cualesquiera dejen de escribir bien esto
cuales quiera
para cualesquiera m y n enteros verdad
ambos tienen que ser números enteros y
en realidad no importa si son 0 pueden
ser distintos pues pueden ser iguales
verdad así que lo que vamos a hacer es
tratar de resolver este problema
reescribiendo toda esta parte de enmedio
utilizando funciones perdón identidades
trigonométricas muy bien que a lo mejor
si no recuerdas muy bien te invito a que
lo revisen en khan academy verdad
entonces vamos a reescribir esto esto es
la integral de 0 a 2 pi y lo que vamos a
ver es que esto es igual a un medio un
medio del seno del seno de m más n por t
m más en el porte y le sumamos el seno
de m - n por t
y todo esto va multiplicando verdad todo
esto sería con respecto a t que de hecho
lo voy a hacer con el color de la
integral que es
entonces esto es desde entonces con está
digamos forma de reescribir lo que
teníamos arriba ahora lo que hacemos es
distribuir este producto vamos a
multiplicar un medio por cada una de
estas dos funciones y entonces esta
primera parte esta primera parte la
ponemos como un medio de la integral de
0 a 2 y déjenme hacer bien es integral
vamos a poner bien la integral la
integral de 0 a 2 pi del seno seno de m
más n por t verdad de t y luego vamos a
poner esta otra parte verdad esta otra
parte sería un medio de la integral de 0
a 2 y del seno de m - n que multiplica t
dt muy bien y de todo esto que es lo que
hay que notar bueno este número de aquí
m n es un número entero verdad porque
pues m y n ambos serán enteros al sumar
los dos
otro entero lo mismo obtenemos acá
verdad m yenes son enteros entonces a la
hora de restar los vuelve a darnos otro
número entero y nosotros sabemos que la
integral del seno de un entero por t
verdad
utilizando esta relación está integral
nos debe dar 0 entonces esta integral de
aquí es 0 esta otra integral de aquí es
0 verdad y en realidad no importa que
estemos multiplicando por un medio
porque un medio por 0 es 0 entonces esto
de aquí nos dio 0 y con esto verificamos
que la relación que habíamos puesto
inicialmente verdad esta de aquí en
efecto nos da 0 y ya lo hemos demostrado